it's always unwise to represent yourself
in any matter let alone a first degree
murder case
however a judge rules Robert tell us
will be allowed to represent himself
during a criminal trial thank you for
joining us here at four I'm Kirsten joy
and I'm Brian Loftus the accused killer
trying to make his case in court this
morning 8 news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy has the latest from the Regional
Justice Center
the judge trying to dissuade Robert tell
us from representing himself pointing
out he doesn't have the experience in
criminal law and if convicted of murder
he could spend the rest of his life in
prison you want to represent yourself in
a first three emergency
Clark County District Court Judge
Michelle Levitt repeatedly telling
Robert tell us it's a bad idea to
represent himself it's almost always
more wise to be represented by counsel I
don't think anyone ever does a good job
representing themselves I don't think
it's a good idea to represent yourself
in a misdemeanor case the former Clark
County public administrator is accused
of killing investigative journalist Jeff
gearman last September after gearman
exposed problems under the leadership of
Telus and Telus then lost the Democratic
primary he is a lawyer telling the judge
for the past seven years while also
admitting he's never handled a jury
trial for a criminal case judge Levitt
warning tell us about rushing a trial
date and Grilling him to show his lack
of knowledge that's not correct judge
Levitt also pointing out defense
attorney Damian cheats who he no longer
wants to be represented by is
knowledgeable and so are the longtime
prosecutors he'd go up against like
Chris Hamner police say they have
evidence like DNA video and more tying
Telus to the scene I'm not playing games
with you this is very very serious you
are charged with first degree murder I
mean you're facing life without the
possibility of parole I would think that
you would take it a little more serious
now at the next scheduled hearing for
this case standby Council will be
discussed Telus expressed interest in
having standby Council this would be
someone who wouldn't represent him
during the criminal trial but would be
on standby to provide guidance to tell
us reporting in downtown Las Vegas
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now